welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn wilshire host and our guest is
Emily Erickson an associate professor of
sociology at Yale University she
conducts research in the fields of
social networks comparative historical
sociology organizations theory and
economics sociology her focus is on the
role of social networks and historical
and cultural change today we'll talk
with Professor Erickson about her new
book between monopoly and free trade the
English East India Company 1602 1757
which was the recipient of the Macmillan
centers 2016 gatos Smith international
book prize for best first book welcome
professor Ericson thanks so much for
having me let's begin with an overview
of your book tell us about it well the
book is about the English East India
Company the English East India Company
was a crown charter monopoly so it was
granted monopoly privileges to exclusive
trade in fact by Queen Elizabeth in 1601
to all the trade east of the Cape of
Good Hope and west of Cape Horn it went
over to the eastern search of spices
coffee tea cotton and it was a
commercial operation until about 1833 or
a monopoly commercial opposite operation
at which time it transferred into a the
foundation of the colonial empire or the
British colonial empire in Asia hmm but
I don't focus on the incipient
colonialism as much as I do on the
commercial aspects and what I found
really compelling about the East India
Company was that it allowed its
employees to engage in a private trade
so the employees traded they had their
own trading operations that they engaged
in in their own self-interest that was
outside of the company's interests so
it's as if you were working at a
restaurant and you and you were the
waitress but you sold drinks to the
customers
and and you profited from that rather
than than the restaurant itself so it's
an unusual unusual situation is it is
and what what sparked your interest in
this what led you to write the book oh
the the first thing that well the
private trade of course was compelling
but I was really interested in this sort
of age of encounters between Asia and
Europe I came out of a history degree at
UC Berkeley where I was introduced to
this incredible book called islands of
history by Marshall Sahlins and that was
about Captain Cook's voyages to Fiji
Hawaii and New Zealand and it's also
sort of about the way that encounters
between different societies can
transform the social structures of those
societies okay and I I just became very
interested in thinking about how these
events could have impacted the societies
civilizations in these in the West okay
so let's talk about about the employee
networks and why do you think the
company allowed their employees to do
such a thing and also were they selling
the company's goods how did that work or
it was their own goods that they were
selling talk a little bit about that oh
sure so essentially the company so this
was difficult it was difficult
conditions right so the employ I mean
they're traveling it takes six months at
least to get to Asia they you know you
have to live on a boat you're not with
your family scurvy was not under control
we're buying at this incredible rate so
it's a thirty-three percent mortality
rate for my business if you can imagine
a company like that nowadays wouldn't
get very far but so they had to offer
inducements to the employees and the
company the English company didn't it
was not in fact all that wealthy or
powerful when it began so the inducement
that they could offer was that they
would allow the employees to engage in
this private trainer and the private
trade was entirely funded by the capital
of the employees the captain's officers
and the semen to a very small extent
because of course you had to have
capital but so they supplied their own
capital their own goods and what were
the goods what were often it was liquor
so Iraq a kind of a liquor there was
mechanical trinkets were very popular
and Wow often also jewels wright and
jewels were attractive to people because
there's a lot of wealth in a compact
form right so that those were the
central commodities okay interesting so
how did you do the the research for the
book I mean how did you go about finding
out about this kind of stuff oh well so
the research so what I did that what was
different that I did in this book was i
use network analysis to illuminate the
in-form patterns of communication
between employees so in order to do
network analysis you have to get
systematic data if that's what was
difficult about that or about the the
research process was I had to find some
kind of systematic data about encounters
between these European and Asian markets
so what I did essentially was I just
combed the stacks I was at Colombian
graduate school so I combed the sacks at
butler library until I found these
incredible volumes and it was sort of
like a gold mine they were a record of
all of a record of the logs of the
journeys of the voyages of the English
East India Company East Indiamen chips
okay so once I got that and then there
was a record of all of the officers
careers also so once I got that then I
had to convert it into electronic format
okay this is something that is so
commonplace now but ten years ago it was
actually a pretty cumbersome process
what was the problem what was the
process what did you have to do I had to
scan all of the pages convert it this
was this was actually right when
converting PDF to text has just been
sort of invented right it would have
just it was really new technology and so
I converted it to text and then I
actually I learned to program so that I
could reorganize all the data although
it still took so many so many I mean
months of cleaning sadly but it's much
faster now you know it's much easier to
engage in this kind of research now so
how did the English East India Company
become one
of the most prominent and enduring
organizations in history well it's a
great question it's an important
question because it sort of flies in the
face of what we think is important about
organizations in general so in sociology
often is sort of ave burien max favor
legacy to think of organizations was all
about hierarchical control but in this
case and this is really one of the most
important earliest companies in history
it wasn't about hierarchical control it
was essentially about ceding power and
autonomy to the employees so they
essentially profit shared by seeding the
exclusive privileges that had been
granted to the company to the employees
they gave the employees all this
autonomy to engage in this private trade
and that translated into informal
collaboration between the employees so
it's really it's profit-sharing autonomy
and collaboration and I would imagine
that also helped the bottom line for the
the English east india company itself
because they had a many employees out in
the world you know doing business
basically absolutely absolutely so those
patterns of behavior they produced the
success of the English East India
Company they made it competitive
compared to the other firms because
drawing on the innovative capacity of
the employees and the way that they
distributed information throughout the
company the firm itself became more
flexible and it was able to adapt to
what we're really volatile market
conditions in overseas trade at that
time did you look at any of the people
who who were at the top who were heading
the company and any history about them
oh well the people that were heading the
company were so interested they were all
against the private trade of course
because they wanted to get as much as
they could out of their exclusive
privileges but they in state they they
couldn't help in order to keep the
company moving they couldn't help but
grant privileges to the employees but
they were all against a so it was
interesting it was an unintended
consequence okay
and so another outcome of this is it
really expanded the trade between Europe
and Asia can you talk a little bit about
what you found there as well oh sure
that's another really great question
because it reveals something I mean the
reason that the English east india
company became a dominant force and
trade between Asia and Europe is really
because of the sophisticated markets
that existed in Asia before before the
English he's sending a company went
there or before any of these large
chartered European companies so
especially the private trade really
depended upon pre-existing merchant
networks and the availability of small
capital loans so essentially what they
needed were open markets would with
pretty sophisticated financial
techniques and and those were were to be
found in spades across Asia which was a
very developed rich sophisticated
commercial world so it was really the
sophistication and complexity of the
markets in Asia that supported the
success of the English east india
company over time and allowed it to
become such such an important figure in
this overseas trade okay and what do you
conclude in your book so I think there's
there's a number of conclusions but the
the ultimate conclusion that i want to
emphasize is that it was the informal
patterns of collaboration between the
company that that between the company
employees that produce the success of
the company so what you can pull out
from that that I think fascinating is
that social networks social networks
that we think of as sort of
interpersonal communication can actually
have these huge impacts on the course of
human history so in this case they
influence through the success of the
company the trajectory of global trade
and politics for centuries and you can
argue that it affected the trajectory of
global trade and politics until brexit
and the end of you know British hedge
ammonia so so these little things
cumulate up and two big outcomes right
interesting so your book is out now yes
and I know you're working on a new
project tell us about it oh so my new
project I'm very excited about it it's
about the development
economic thought in the 17th century and
I have a lot of evidence that shows that
it's actually very closely tied to the
rise of Chartered companies at the same
time of which the English East India
Company was one of these charter
companies so are you looking all over
the world globally or are you focused on
basically that the colonial empire oh
yeah I am focused it's mostly so
economic thought is mostly an English
phenomenon at this time so I do a little
bit of a comparative cases especially
with the Dutch Republic because you
think that the Dutch were a little more
advanced than the English at that time
you would think they would have produced
economic thought but they didn't make
any significant contributions
interesting and they also didn't really
have the same number of companies and
they not it was not as widespread in the
Netherlands which i think is really one
of the keys to to this sort of puzzle
right right well we will look forward to
that book coming out in the near future
thanks so much and it's been great to
have you it's been great to be here
thank you for more information about
professor Erickson and her research
please visit our website at macmillan
report yale edu be sure to join us again
for another episode of the macmillan
report made possible through funding
from the Whitney and Betty Macmillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale
you